now the numbers here are simple enough
but actually if I really wanted to I
could list this whole thing out okay
which we are going to do at the end of
this sort can verify that we get the
right on top but of course it's not that
hard to change this to be something that
you can't just list out I could just say
do that I mean you'd say you know flip
the table on your home okay so let's
just consider this is a simple one
enough so at the end of this we can
verify our arts are in order to get to
this what the greatest coefficient is I
need to know what the coefficients are
need to get to that ratio and I want to
find for which terms is that ratio
continually getting bigger ok so to
start with let's think about what are
the terms and then let's pull out the
coefficient ok so for example what is
the cake term of this of this particular
thing I'll give you a clue it starts
with 5c ok am I going to write next what
are the extra bits 105 minus K ok I'm
going to pause you there you may have
noticed maybe work repentigny because
you're wrong with it first we had said
yes and then secondly he said this ok
let's just pause for a bit both of those
are ok can someone tell me why yeah okay
so when I'm saying their general turn
right you can start from one end and to
walk through or you can start from the
other end and walk the other way and
they both give you the same turns right
they will still generate the same six
terms just you write them backwards ok
now I'm going to ask you in a second
because actually does make a minor
difference which one of these is better
if you see it immediately don't tell me
but think about it and how would you
work out why one is better than the
other ok let's just finish it off let's
try the first one first so if i write k
up here I've got the binomial
coefficient I've been got this part
however many of them I have how many of
these will I have if i have k ok good so
i'm going to write it like so ok so i've
got that that's fine how do i write at
the other way
yeah that's right all these never do is
switch around ok so I could write it
like this ok now i don't think it's
immediately obvious just set at least it
wasn't to me what Ellen this which of
these is superior so what I'm going to
do before I you know open the veil and
spoil it for everyone for those who have
already worked it out I don't just need
term Kane right to actually solve this
coefficient thing I need to compare to
the next one yes ok so what I'm going to
do is I'm also going to write PK plus 1
and i'm going to write it both ways as
well just so you can see i hope it
becomes a little clearer okay so if i'm
wrong with the first scheme let's just
follow this across if that's ok what
does term k plus 1 look like start with
the binomial coefficient mm-hmm is that
bit and then I'm going to have the next
power of 1 which is one to the k plus 1
and then I'm going to have the small
power of this right so this is coming to
be 3x yeah before I simplify I'm going
to write it I'm just going to do a
straight substitution so it's actually
five take away the new value of R which
in this case is k plus 1 you can see how
just on a swamp and then i'm going to
write it in the other skin ok so here is
my other way of writing to you k plus 1
i still have the same binomial
coefficient out the front and then I'll
have this guy
okay now last step before it it becomes
really clear I hope which one of these
is better right do I go with option one
or do I go with option two right what am
I going to do with these things I
actually don't need this whole term is
only a part of it that I need which part
do I need have a look yeah I just need
the numerical part i'm not interested in
the X is the variable bit I need to pull
out just the numbers and use those
that's what's going to for my ratio okay
so let me just underline them for you do
you see let's have a look this is a
number it's just a number no variables
this is a number and this part here the
three is going to be a number and then I
sort of abandoned the X right in the
same way oh this is a number and this is
another and then this is a number and I
abandoned the X okay and once I do those
have those things right I'm then going
to divide them and hopefully there'll be
some funky canceling that happens that
makes things nice and neat I have a look
okay if you are going to choose either
this one or this one you're going to
choose either this one or this one which
do you think is going to be easier to
work with and cancel out the answer is
option two this one here okay let me put
a box around it the reason why it's so
much easier to use and I'm pointing this
out making big deal out of it because
frequently this number will be one not
always but frequently okay I'm see how
this is like some messy grows power
right see you and even this one is not
that much it doesn't matter I don't care
like that Paris because just one any
power of one will always be one okay so
immediately I can just ignore him and my
my cancelling out my arithmetic becomes
subsequently much easier whereas if I'm
trying to mess with this guy like I'm
asking to make a mistake right so
therefore even though I could write it
like this and sometimes you will not
have a choice sometimes both of these
numbers will be somewhat messy okay when
I do have a choice I'm gonna write a
second way because in a second when I
pull out the coefficients the ones in
just vanish away